will lawlessness inherit the kingdom of
God we're going to go to the scriptures
and find out because I don't think what
we see Christianity Today I don't think
it's the same Christianity that we saw
back in the Bible days I think what we
see today is a lukewarm Christianity
that looks nothing like what it
originally used to look like and we're
just going to see does it even matter
because there are a lot of people that
say look man I believe Jesus is Lord I
believe that he's a Son of God he died
for my sins that's all matters you know
when I die I'm Kingdom bound it doesn't
matter what I do in this life it this is
just One Life to Live right just live it
up have fun do whatever you want to do I
lived like that as a Christian for eight
and a half years I was a self-professed
Christian that was a rapper a fornicator
a weed smoker a a drinker an alcoholic I
was doing all those things under the
banner of I'm a Christian because I
wasn't in the word of God myself and I
was actually believing what I was
hearing from other believers including
my family and I had my cousin was
telling me man you're like King Solomon
you got all the girls you know that
Jesus turned water into wine you got all
the free beer he says you know that
Genesis says that every green herb
bearing seed is for man look Satan loves
to use scripture when he was in the
Garden of Eden he spoke to Eve and he
said did God not say you could eat of
every tree in the garden well yeah but
when you you leave the last part off 99%
truth is not truth when Jes or when
Satan was tempting Jesus in the
wilderness he was quoting scripture but
the Lord was using scripture back at him
and he was using it in context we're
going to get right into the scriptures
and see what the scriptures have to say
I think this is such a vital topic
because I believe Jesus is coming soon
and I want to be ready I want to be
ready when he comes I want my friends
and family to be ready and I think we
have a duty here on Earth I think while
we're here we're not just supposed to be
partying it up and saying well I'm a
believer I'm good to go no we got a
mission in this life and that's to
spread the word of God and and to be a
living reflection of the character of
Christ to draw all men unto himself
through us because they'll see something
that we have that they desire which is
Hope and peace and love [snorts] first
we're going to look at the Commandments
of God because
are they important today are the
Commandments of God important you know
when I was growing up as a Believer um
you know I didn't think we were like
Ultra conservative or anything it was a
non-denominational church and it was
like the Ten Commandments are listed on
the wall you go to churches there's Ten
Commandments statues monuments and
framed pictures Christian are the Ten
Commandments that's like Christianity
101 but now it seems like today people
are like oh man that's like legalism
That's the Law like you know got to keep
that and so I want to look at that is
that important today is are the Ten
Commandments important
we want to start out with Romans 6 a lot
of people bring up like come on man
we're not under the law have you read
Romans you read Galatians
I want to look at some things in Romans
6 because Paul you know people love to
use Paul to say that we don't have to
keep the law anymore that we don't have
to we can be Lawless but Paul was saying
things like what shall we say then this
is chapter 6 verse one what shall we say
then shall we continue in sin that Grace
May abound then he says God forbid how
shall we that are dead to sin live any
longer therein so Paul's saying like
look come on just because we're not
under the law because we're saved by
grace does that mean that we should sin
continue in sin no notice it uses the
word continue in sin should we continue
in sin meaning the sinful nature that
you used to have so that Grace May
abound and he says God forbid it's like
the strongest way that he can say no way
for he that is dead is freed from sin
now if we be dead in Christ we believe
that we shall also live with him knowing
that Christ being raised from the dead
dieth no more death hath no more
dominion over him
for in that he died he died into unto
sin once but in that he liveth he liveth
unto God likewise reckon ye also
yourselves that to be dead indeed unto
sin but alive unto God through Jesus
Christ Our Lord let not sin therefore
reign in your mortal body that ye may
that ye should obey it in the lust
thereof meaning look don't let lust
which that that doesn't mean just um
Desiring after a woman the lust of the
flesh is all kinds of things the desire
to drink the desire to smoke weed or the
desire to gamble all these things are
lust of the flesh he's saying don't let
sin abound
neither yield your members as
instruments of unrighteousness Unto sin
but yield yourselves unto God as those
that are alive from the dead and your
members as instruments of righteousness
unto God he's saying don't don't give
into that stuff make your body an
instrument unto God for sin shall not
have dominion over you for ye are not
under the law but under grace see this
is the type of stuff that people do they
they pull out that one verse you're not
under law man you're under grace but
what does all this talk look at the
context it's all saying do not yield to
sin do not do the former things of the
lust of the Flesh
and he says what then shall we sin
because we are not under the law but
under grace God forbid so what is the
very definition of sin it's the breaking
of the law there without the law there
is no sin so anyone that says look man
there is no law anymore that means that
there's no sin anymore because without a
law you can't break the law so therefore
there can't be sin anymore but we know
there's sin we know there's tons of sin
in the world that's what Jesus came to
set us free from so Paul repeatedly says
God forbid that we sin against God's law
so Paul taught to keep God's law in
Romans 3:31
he said do we then make void the law
through faith God forbid yay we
establish the law so this isn't even in
Romans 6 this is in Romans chapter 3 all
through Romans I love it because he's
straight up and he says do we make void
the law God forbid we establish the law
what does that mean it sure doesn't mean
that we throw it away sure doesn't mean
it's done away with and gone 1
Corinthians 7:19 says circumcision is
nothing and uncircumcision is nothing so
he's talking about like these uh the
mosaic laws and all this stuff he's
saying look that stuff's nothing man
that's the that's the flesh that's the
cutting a way of the flesh but we're
talking about the heart laws right he
says circumcision is nothing
uncircumcision is nothing but keeping
the Commandments of God is what matters
the Commandments of God you know I hear
people say no we're not under the
Commandments of God we're under the new
commandments of Jesus we're going to get
into that Jesus never made any new
Commandments he added to the law but he
never took away from the law so keeping
the Commandments of God is what matters
that's from Paul in First Corinthians
Jesus himself said now look we can't
disagree with Jesus you might want to
say hey I don't know about Paul and this
and that but this is coming from Jesus
Matthew 7:16 through 23 he said ye shall
know them by their fruits now what does
that mean know them by their fruits this
means that just because someone says hey
I'm a Christian look at me I got I got a
cross necklace on I wear a Jesus shirt I
got a Bible in my hand I go to church
every week those things do they tell you
if that person's a Christian or not
no what does Jesus say you'll know them
by their fruits and what are their
fruits the fruits are the things that
come outward from the Holy Spirit the
fruits of the spirit are love joy peace
patience all these things right that's
how you know a true Christian you can
you should be able to spot a Christian
without any kind of cross or a Bible in
their hand just by the way they act
their character by their character you
will know them he says do men gather
Grapes of thorns or figs of thistles
even so every good tree bringeth forth
good fruit but a corrupt tree bringeth
forth evil fruit a good tree cannot
bring forth evil fruit interesting a
good tree cannot bear evil fruit so if
you're a Christian
can you call are you a Christian if
you're part participating in sinful
things for forication drunkenness
intoxicating your mind no it says a good
tree can not bring forth evil fruit
neither can a corrupt tree bring forth
good fruit every tree that bringeth not
forth good fruit listen to this every
tree that bringeth not forth good fruit
is heun down and cast into the fire that
is strong language this is the
destruction of the wicked so if you're
saying you're a Christian and you're a
Believer but you have no fruit you are
to be cut down and cast Into the Fire
just like a tree that never bears fruit
you wouldn't keep that in your yard it's
just a it's just a stumbling block it's
just a a hindrance in your yard who
wants a tree that doesn't have any kind
of fruit or leaves or anything
cast Into the Fire wherefore by their
fruits ye shall know them now this is
important not everyone that saith unto
me Lord Lord now would an atheist say
Lord Lord no because they don't believe
in Jesus who's saying Lord Lord those
who profess to be Believers not everyone
that saith unto me Lord Lord shall enter
into the Kingdom of Heaven that
statement right there says belief alone
is not the key it's not that's what it
says and otherwise it would say everyone
that says to me Lord Lord will enter the
kingdom but it doesn't it says not
everyone that says to me Lord Lord will
enter the kingdom of heaven but he that
what doeth the will of My Father which
is in heaven that is clear I'm going to
put this fo on the screen because I
noticed it's kind of small
so it says right there not everyone that
says Lord Lord but he that doeth
he that doeth the will of My Father
which is in heaven those are the ones
who are getting into the kingdom he says
many not not some not a few not Remnant
many will say to me in that day Lord
Lord have we not prophesied in your name
and in your name have cast out devils
and in thy name have done many wonderful
works and I will profess unto them I
never knew you depart from me ye that
work iniquity which is the word
lawlessness
now think about this statement here
he's saying I never knew you knowing
someone is a relationship term so no
you're not going to earn your way to
heaven get that out of your mind a lot
of people they jump to that conclusion
oh you must believe in Works based
salvation I don't all of us have sinned
and fallen short of the glory of God
none of us can work our way to heaven
because we've already broke the rules we
already deserve hell there's no way we
can redeem ourselves from that we broke
the law the law the breaking of the law
is death the wages of sin is death we've
all done it but Christ died in our place
so that we don't have to die that death
all we have to do is believe in him what
does it mean to believe in him to trust
and Obey because when you believe in
someone or something you'll do what they
say right if you believe in your doctor
and they say look you have a clogged
artery in your heart if you don't change
your diet today you will die and this is
what you need to do and this is what you
need to take will you do it well yeah
because you believe in them they saw it
on the X-ray they they know what they're
talking about so you're going to obey
them right or you could say well I
believe the doctor but I don't need to
change anything I'm good to go I believe
in the doctor thank you Holy Spirit like
that just came to me I never used that
analogy before but the idea of like just
believing your doctor telling you you're
sick doesn't make you well it doesn't
save you you have to obey trust and Obey
there's no other way right so he's
saying so get the idea out of your mind
that works are going to save you they
won't there's plenty of good atheists
out there that will not make it to
heaven but he's also saying look you're
Lawless and I don't know you I don't
have a relationship with you because
salvation is a relationship term it's
not it's not a Works thing look if I
if I did a lot of good works for my wife
if I washed her car and gave her roses
and chocolates but I never spent any
time with I just like I dropped it off
at the house like a delivery man and and
went away that's not a relationship
right they're good nice works and she
would say oh that was kind but she would
never say me and my husband have a great
relationship because I did some kind
works right and if I you know I just
I don't know like there's a different
when a relationship it has fruit that's
what we're talking about the fruit right
so he's saying depart from me I never
knew you workers of lawlessness that's
that's deep That's Heavy right there
Matthew 5:1 17-19 this is what Jesus
himself said he said think not that I am
come to destroy the law boom he did not
destroy the law and he said or the
prophets and then he says I am not come
to destroy
but to fulfill now a lot of people look
at this and they'll say yeah that means
he got rid of it but that doesn't make
any sense because if that's the case
Jesus basically just said I've not come
to destroy the law but to destroy it it
doesn't make sense the word fulfill
means that he walked it out perfectly we
know that Jesus was sinless and what
does that mean it means that he kept the
law perfectly in a way that we never
could in a way we never did he kept it
perfect not one time did he ever sin he
fulfilled the law
but he didn't destroy it he said I am
not com to destroy the law next Verse 18
He says for verily I say unto you till
Heaven and Earth pass we're still here
it has not passed away till Heaven and
Earth pass one jot or one tit shall in
no wise pass from the law till all be
fulfilled we're still here Heaven and
Earth is still here that has not
fulfilled yet it will there'll come a
time when the elements will melt with
fervent Heat and the Earth will pass
away with a great noise and that's at
the second coming but even then the law
is not going to pass away the law is
eternal but we are still here on Earth
so therefore the law is still here
whosoever therefore shall break one of
the least Commandments think about that
the least commandment someone might say
well I never murdered yeah I've told a
bunch of lies and and things like that
the least commandment and shall teach
men so he shall be called the least in
the Kingdom of Heaven but whosoever
shall do
and teach them the same Shall be Called
great in the Kingdom of Heaven so look
we're supposed to be doing them and
teaching them and yet Christians today
will say man stop doing that stop
telling people they got to keep the
Commandments of the law that is legalism
you legalistic Pharisee they'll say
don't do it but the Bible Jesus himself
says do do it and says we'll be called
great in the Kingdom of Heaven for doing
it for doing it and for teaching it and
notice it says that those who break the
least commandment we be called least in
the Kingdom of Heaven this is not saying
well at least I'll be there I'm just
going to be like a janitor in heaven no
there's no ranking in heaven like that
it's saying you're going to be called
least by the Kingdom of Heaven the the
beings in heaven right now are going to
be looking down on Earth and saying that
person is the least you'll be called
least by the Kingdom of Heaven
that should be very strong language so
Jesus said that the Commandments hang on
love I believe on that I believe in that
a lot of people will say look man all
you got to do is love God and love your
neighbor that's what Jesus said that is
so true it's absolutely true 100% I
agree with it Jesus said the
Commandments hang on love notice the Ten
Commandments are exactly that how do you
love God how do you show that you love
God you will not worship any other gods
you will not make any Idols you will not
misuse his name and you will keep his
Sabbath day holy those are the four
those are the first four Commandments
and they all teach you how to love God
these are the fruits of how to love God
you'll know them by the fruits how do
you love man honor your father and
mother that's how you love your parents
do not murder that's how you love your
neighbors not don't murder them do not
commit adultery if you love your wife
you're not going to cheat on her do not
steal if you love your neighbor you're
not going to take their things do not
lie and do not covet this is how you
love your neighbor all the Commandments
hang on love love God and love your
neighbor
Jesus said that the Commandments hang on
love this is what he said I'm going to
share the verse with you Matthew 24:
35-40
and he said then one of them which was a
lawyer asked him a question tempting him
and saying Master which of the Great
commandment which is the greatest
commandment in the law
Jesus said unto him Thou shalt love the
Lord thy God with all thine heart and
with all thy soul and with all thy mind
this is the first and great commandment
so we're supposed to love God above any
anyone else no other gods before him not
your wife not your children not your
family your mom and dad no one God is
first and then he says this is the first
and great commandment and the second is
like unto it Thou shalt Love Thy
Neighbor as thyself on these two
Commandments hang all the law and and
the prophets
so he wasn't being he wasn't being
tricky about it he's just saying look
you're trying to Temp me you're trying
to trick me I'm going to tell you that
if you love God and you love your
neighbor you fulfilled the whole law
because by their fruits you will know
this how do you know that somebody loves
their wife by the way they treat them
right if they're screaming and yelling
and kicking her out of the house and all
you'll know he doesn't love his wife by
his fruit but because he loves her he'll
treat her that way
so the law is now written on our hearts
you hear people say that you read it in
the New Testament that he's going to put
his law in our hearts does that mean
we're going to throw it out because
that's what people say like no no no I'm
I'm a New Covenant Christian I don't got
to keep the law
but Jesus said he's going to write it on
your heart that doesn't mean you throw
it away that's like the opposite that
means you're in love with the law now
it's written on your heart it's not just
written in stone now it's on your person
in Hebrews 10:16 it says this is the
Covenant that I will make with them
after those days sayeth the Lord I will
put my laws into their hearts and in
their minds I will write them this means
the beliefs of your mind now you believe
them and you love them with all your
heart and of course you're GNA obey them
if you if you believe them and you love
them of course it makes sense you're
gonna obey them
is having his law in our hearts new is
this A New Concept to have the law
written in our heart Psalm 37:31 that's
old testament old testament Psalms of
David it says the law of his God is in
his heart none of this none of his steps
shall side slide yeah so a lot of people
say look I'm a New Covenant Christian I
this is new I just follow the promptings
of the Holy Spirit I don't need to read
the Bible I don't need to keep the law
the Holy Spirit tells me what to do
there's nothing new about having the law
written on your heart this goes all the
way back to David in the Psalms Psalms
40:8 says I Delight to do thy will oh my
God yay thy law is within my heart so
it's in his heart and what does that
mean that he Delights to do it I Delight
to do God's will I God has freed me and
transformed my life from The Reckless
Lawless person that I was and I love
God's law because now I see wait a
minute when I do it my own way I mess up
my life I mess up other people's lives
and I realize that that's not loving my
neighbor when I disobey God's
Commandments I'm not loving my neighbor
because I'm doing everything I shouldn't
do Psalm 119 34 says give me
understanding and I shall keep thy law
yay I shall observe it with my whole
heart again it's talking about keeping
the law with your whole heart having it
written in your heart
it goes on Proverbs this is in Proverbs
Old Testament still 3 verse1 my son
forget not my law but let thine heart
keep my Commandments thy heart keep my
Commandments
Isaiah 51:7 says hearken unto me ye that
know righteousness the people in whose
heart is my law fear ye not which
reproach of men neither be ye afraid of
their revilings so it's like don't even
worry about men
keep your heart on my law if you love me
keep my Commandments that's another one
that comes up Ecclesiastes 12:13 this
one is great let us hear the conclusion
of the whole matter fear God and keep
his Commandments for this is the whole
duty of man boom case closed that right
there tells you and if people say no no
that's the Old Testament or whatever the
scriptures say that all of scripture was
divinely inspired by the Holy Spirit and
is profitable for Doctrine for reprove
and all these things like do you believe
it do you believe that all of scripture
was inspired by the Holy Spirit yes and
it says fear God keep his Commandments
for this is the whole duty of man
since the Commandments are based on
loving God and loving your neighbor
Jesus said this John 1415 if you love me
keep my Commandments that's straight
from the words of Jesus we shouldn't
even be having a discussion about this
anymore if you love me keep my
Commandments but there will be people
out there that say no Jesus had new
commandments so we got to address that
stuff I'm going to try to leave no stone
unturned with this John 14 20:21
at that day ye shall know that I am in
my father and ye in me and I in you he
that hath my Commandments and keepeth
them he it is that loveth me and he that
loveth me shall be loved of my father
and I will love him and will manifest my
myself to him this is amazing he he's
saying if you love me keep my
Commandments and he's saying
he who loves me or he who keeps my
Commandments are the ones who love me
it's so clear
he that hath my Commandments and keepeth
them he it is that loveth me
amazing
John 15 8-14 says herein is my father
glorified that ye bear much fruit here
we go we need fruit what does that look
like what's it mean to bear fruit Jesus
said you'll know them by their fruits
and here it says herein is my father
herein is my father glorified that ye
bear much fruit so shall ye be my
disciples as the father hath loved me so
hath I loved you continue ye in my love
so now he's talking about love and he's
talking about fruit and the very next
verse says if ye keep my Commandments ye
shall abide in my love even as I have
kept my father's Commandments and abide
in his love
that is beautiful are you kidding me if
you love me you'll have fruit and the
fruit is you're keeping my Commandments
and you're proving that you love me
you're proving that you believe in me
because all it is is belief if you
believe in Jesus you'll do what he says
these things have I spoken unto you that
my Joy might remain in you and that your
joy might be full if you keep his
Commandments you're going to have joy
this is my commandment that ye love one
another as I have loved you greater love
hath no man than this that a man lay
down his life for his friends ye are my
friends if you do whatever I command you
so yeah a lot of people say look he just
said it almost looks like a new
commandment he's saying if you love me
you keep my Commandments but my
commandment is to love one another but
then he ends up saying if you do
whatever I command you which are the
Commandments which hang on love which
are the fruit and they prove that you
love God they prove that you love Christ
you don't know him if John 2: 3-7 says
and hereby we do know that we know him
if we keep his commands ments so we know
that we know him if we keep his
Commandments he that saith I know him
and keepeth not his Commandments is a
liar
and the truth is not in him this is
strong language this is clear I mean if
anyone thought that this was an absurd
like obscure
thing that we don't know well maybe you
should maybe you should and maybe have
to I don't know we've only gone through
half of this so far and this is so clear
he that keepeth not his Commandments is
a liar and the truth is not in him Jesus
is the way the truth and the life if
he's the truth and the truth is not in
you then Christ is not in you if you
don't keep the Commandments but who so
keepeth his words but who so keepeth his
word in him verily is the love of God
perfected
hereby know we that we are in him he
that saith he abideth in him ought
himself also so to walk even as he
walked so if we say that we abide with
Christ we ought to be walking the way
Christ walked do you think Jesus went
around sinning no we know for a fact he
didn't
how can we say look I don't have to keep
the law I'm not under that quit being a
legalist I'm a New Covenant Christian I
do what I want to and I'm still going to
go to heaven you're going to rise up and
say Lord Lord
I did all these things in your name he's
going to say I never knew you you
workers of lawlessness
Brethren I write no new commandment unto
you wo so clear but an old commandment
which ye had from the beginning the
Commandment was not a mosaic thing
either
Cain killed Abel
Cain was the first murderer on Earth and
he came way before Moses
and it was a sin to murder it was a sin
when Lucifer put himself above God and
made himself an idol Lucifer broke the
Commandments because the Commandments
are Eternal they didn't come when they
were written in stone to Moses they're
Eternal they have been ever in the past
and will ever go in the future for all
eternity the Commandments are Eternal
the old commandment is the word which ye
have heard from [snorts] the beginning
if anyone had a doubt in their mind that
Jesus maybe had a new commandment he
says I I do not give you a new
commandment but an old commandment which
one the one you've heard from the
beginning that said that murder was a
sin when Cain slew Abel
so clear I love God's word Cuts Like a
two-edged sword come on
Romans 13 8-7 says oh no man anything
but to love one another for he that
loveth one another has fulfilled the law
and how do you love one another by
keeping the first but the last six
Commandments for this here we go into it
for this Thou shalt not commit adultery
Thou shalt not kill he's quoting The Ten
Commandments Thou shalt not steal Thou
shalt not bear false witness Thou shalt
not covet if there be any other
commandment it is briefly comprehended
in this saying namely Thou shalt love
thy neighbor as thyself look he's
starting to quote Commandments he's like
look if I left out any others it's
summed up like this just love your
neighbor because if you love him you're
not going to steal from him you're not
going to adultery you're not going to
murder him and it says love worketh no
ill to his neighbor therefore love is
the fulfilling of the law
why are we trying to go against the Ten
Commandments there The Ten Commandments
are love it's the law of love the law of
Liberty and freedom and love and joy and
peace why would anyone fight against the
Commandments
why would any Christian fight against
the Commandments even an atheist would
agree with most of the Commandments
maybe not the first four but the last
six they'd say yeah this is good we
should do these things
1 John 52-4 says by this we know that we
love the children of God when we love
God and keep his Commandments
see we can't take script out of context
you can't make entire doctrines out of
one verse like we're not under the law
but under grace that's it you're saved
do what you want to do what about all
these verses that say pick up your cross
daily die to the lust of the flesh he
who endures to the end shall be saved
endure what if it's just a once save
always save I said the prayer I'm good
to go we must endure and pick up our
cross daily and he who gets across the
Finish Line will win Crown of Life it
says for this is the love of God now
we're going to we're going to clarify
this is the love of God that we keep his
Commandments and his Commandments are
not Grievous
look we shouldn't be like a man I really
want to commit adultery right now but
I won't because the Commandment says not
to no they are not Grievous to us
because we've been transformed by the
renewing of our mind we are new
creatures in Christ we're not the same
people I used to love
alcohol I used to love marijuana I used
to love sleeping around and now I hate
those things because God has transformed
my mind he's given me a new character
I'm a new creature in Christ I hate the
things I used to love only Christ can do
that he's the only one and eventually
people who reject Christ for so long
will reach rock bottom and they'll
realize that he's who they've been
looking for the whole time when they
tried to fill it with sex and drugs and
alcohol it was him they were looking for
they were trying to find Joy they were
trying to find peace and hope and it's
Christ and he's the only one that can
set you free from addiction from
fornication from bondage of anything
for whatsoever is born of God overcometh
the world and this is the victory that
overcometh the world even our faith our
faith in Christ is the one that gives us
Victory because if we have faith in him
we'll do what he says and that's victory
over sin it's amazing if we put our
faith in him we'll surrender to him
that's what I had to do
when I was in bondage to addiction I
tried In My Own Strength I said today
I'm not gonna drink today I'm not GNA
smoke weed and guess what my neighbors
my friends would show up say what's up
man let's drink I got some beer I got
some weed and i' I'd give to the temp
Temptation I couldn't do it in My Own
Strength you can't White Knuckle and
overcome sin maybe for a time you know
how many people I've had reach out to me
and say how' you get Victory man I want
what you got and I said it was full
surrender I told God on New Year's 2013
take this out of my life I don't want it
anymore I give you permission to remove
it and God set me free overnight
instantaneous supernaturally I couldn't
do that I had withdrawals every day that
I didn't drink or smoke and I was set
free overnight why because I surrendered
I put my faith in Christ and my faith
gave me the victory I couldn't do it in
My Own Strength
Jesus is the only one
victory over sin and sin is what sin is
transgression of the law it's the Bible
definition of sin it's transgression of
the law
I'm G put this full screen so you guys
can read this
Jesus gives us victory over sin like I
was just talking about 1 John 34-11
says whosoever committeth sin
transgresseth also the law for sin is
the transgression of the law so if
anyone wants to well what is a sin what
isn't a sin is this a sin anymore
is breaking the Commandments of sin yes
or no simple question is breaking the
Comm Commandments of God a sin to God or
a sin against man yes hands down 100%
and ye know that he was manifested to
take away our sins and in him is no sin
whosoever abideth in him sinth not so if
we abide in Christ we will not sin
whosoever sinth hath not seen him
neither know him knowing being in a
relationship if you're in a relationship
with Christ he can give you victory over
sin when we stray away from Christ we
fall into temptation we fall into sin
thank God that when we sin on occasion
not when we live in lawlessness but in
those times that we stumble we have an
advocate with the father and he is
faithful and just to forgive us our sins
when we confess our sins to him when we
confess and repent he's faithful and
just to forgive us our sins but now it's
up to us to go and sin no more right in
a righteous falls seven times and gets
back up he doesn't stay down so don't
fall into temptation and say well I'm
already down I might as well stay down
here no let Christ pick you up by the
hand like a child that stumbles when
he's walking and say I'll be by your
side you won't fall this time because
I'm with you I abide with you
and then he really uses that analogy
little children let no man deceive you
he that doeth righteousness is righteous
even as he is righteous
he that committeth sin is of the devil
for the devil sinth from the beginning
for this purpose the Son of God was
manifested that he might destroy the
works of the devil which is sin
whosoever is born of God doth not commit
sin for his seed remaineth in him and he
cannot sin because he is born of God now
this doesn't mean that when we sin it's
not sin
it doesn't mean that he's saying if
you're born of God you won't sin because
sin is a let me let me
sin is a verb and I will I will tell you
I don't sin meaning I don't live in
habitual sin I will stumble and fall
into sin but I don't live in iniquity
there's a difference in sin and iniquity
sin is an AR term when you pull back the
arrow the bow and you have your sight
set on the bullseye and you let go
you're going for the Target right you're
you're wanting and Desiring to hit the
bullseye but along the path to the
bullseye a gust of wind blows it off
course that's the definition of sin you
had your the eye on the prize you had
your sight set on the right thing but
something came along that was too big of
a Temptation for you and you stumbled
and you fell
and you felt guilty for it and you felt
shame about it and you came to Christ
and you said Lord forgive me I confess
my sins
please wash me white as snow he will do
that he's faithful and just to forgive
you to forgive us our sins but iniquity
is much different iniquity means you
know what I see that commandment and I
know it's true I see it written right
there do not commit adultery but you
know what it feels too good and I'm
going to do it anyway I'm I'm still a
Believer I believe in the Commandments I
believe in Jesus but that I'm going to
do it because it feels good and I'm
going to do it tomorrow and you know
what I'm already scheduling for next
week I'm going to do it again
that's iniquity that's lawlessness
you're literally walking away from the
father at that point you're not abiding
with him and you become the prodical son
when you choose willfully to turn your
back on Christ walk away from what he's
commanded to do he's no longer your Lord
because why callest me Lord if you do
not do the things I ask you right the
things I command you if someone is your
Lord and Master you will obey them but
when you willfully choose not stumbling
on occasion not falling into temptation
but willfully choosing to walk away
Christ lets you walk away he never
forces anyone in a relationship with him
no one's going to get to heaven and say
I didn't ask to be here I didn't want to
be here no one's going to we all get
what we want and if you choose the world
Christ will give you the world but guess
what his arms are wide open waiting for
his prodical son to return and he's
going to run and meet you and put a ring
on your finger and kiss you and say I've
been waiting for you my son I've been
waiting for you to return but he's never
going to force himself upon you so
anyone that says no no once saved always
saved no one can pluck you out of the
hands of God that's true no one can
pluck you out but you you can choose to
jump out of his hands but no one else in
this world can make you come out of
relationship with Christ
I hope that's clear man I hope that's
clear
let's finish it says whosoever is born
of God doeth not commit doth not commit
sin for his seed remaineth in him and he
cannot sin because he is born of God in
this the children of God God are
manifest and the children of the devil
whosoever doeth not righteousness is not
of God neither he that loveth not his
brother for this is the message that ye
have heard from the beginning that we
should love one another
man God's word is so clear if there's
any sin that we are cherishing so much
that we will willfully do it we are
Lawless and we are choosing to turn our
backs on Christ whether that's
homosexuality
whether that's drunkenness whether
that's adultery and pornography
these things and don't say oh it's an
addiction I can't overcome Jesus gave me
the victory I was a slave to alcohol and
marijuana anyone that says that says
marijuana is not addictive is in pure
ignorance willful ignorance because
every day I didn't have marijuana I
spent the whole day looking for it I was
irritable I was Snappy my friends and
I've seen it with many of my other
friends and relatives and loved ones
if you choose to be in bondage to these
addictions
then we are Lawless
surrender is the only way to have
Victory surrender to Christ today if
something is binding you up tell Jesus I
don't want it in my life I don't have
the power but you do I'm weak you are
strong take this out of my life I don't
want it anymore I give you permission to
take it out because says God will not
remove anything out of your life that
you're cherishing God is not a thief if
you're cherishing a sin he's not going
to rip it from your hands and pry it out
of your hands he's not a thief he
doesn't break into homes he's not
busting down doors he's knocking on the
door your heart and he's saying do you
believe me do you trust me I have a
better way for you I can give you the
victory but you have to let me do the
work it's all about surrender guys
that's the only way I got to where I'm
at
2 John 1 5-7 says and now I beeech Thee
lady not as though I write a new not as
though I wrote a new commandment unto
thee but that which we had from the
beginning that we love one another I'm
showing these verses because so many
people say that Jesus made some new
Commandments it's not true look how many
times this is the third time we've read
that he said not a new commandment but
the one from the beginning and this is
love that we walk after his Commandments
this is the Commandment that as ye have
heard from the beginning you should walk
in it for many deceivers are entered
into the world who confess not that
Jesus Christ Has Come In the Flesh this
is a deceiver and is an antichrist
so anyone that comes in this world who's
a deceiver whether that's
a Believer or a non-believer anyone who
says that the Commandments are done away
with is Antichrist
because Jesus is Love right I believe
that do you believe that Jesus is Love
Now what did he say the Commandments are
the Commandments are love if the
Commandments are love and Jesus is love
and love and the Commandments and Jesus
are all one then if you say there's no
Commandments and there's no law then
you're throwing out Jesus
it's that simple it's math it's like
Commandments equal love Jesus equals
love if you say no Commandments then you
say No Love No Jesus it's as simple as
that
the Antichrist is the Lawless one why
are Christians trying to be Lawless
do you realize this I'm going put this
full screen
let no one deceive you by any means this
is 2 Thessalonians 2 37-12
let no one deceive you by any means for
that day will not come unless there be a
falling away first and the man of sin is
revealed the son of predition for the
mystery of lawlessness
is already at work only he who now
restrains will do so unto until he is
taken out of away and then the Lawless
one will be revealed who's the Lawless
one the Antichrist the devil Satan
himself
the Lawless one will be revealed whom
the Lord will consume with the breath of
his mouth and Destroy with the
brightness of his coming look if we're
living in lawlessness if we're saying
the Commandments don't matter anymore we
will be consumed at his coming we will
not be a part of the Kingdom the coming
of the law Lawless one is according to
the working of Satan the Lawless one is
Satan with all power signs and lying
wonders and with all unrighteous
deception among those who perish because
they did not have a love of the truth
that they might be saved what is the
truth Jesus is the truth and the
Commandments are love and Jesus is the
way the truth and the life and love if
he is the Commandments if he is Love and
Truth the Commandments are ling truth
that means if you do not love the
Commandments then you are with the devil
and you will not be saved that's what it
says they did not receive a love of the
truth that they might be saved and for
this reason God will send them strong
delusion that they should believe the
lie that they all may be consumed who
did not believe the truth but had
pleasure in unrighteousness
lawlessness and unrighteousness
is going to be consumed at the
brightness of his coming
Matthew 7:16 through 23 says you will
know them by their fruits we read this
one earlier it says therefore by their
fruits you will know them not everyone
that says Lord Lord shall enter the
kingdom but only those that do the will
of my father and then at the bottom it
says
and then I will declare to them I never
knew you depart from me you who practice
lawlessness is this making sense guys
lawlessness will say
I never knew you and depart from me
lawlessness will not inherit the kingdom
of God
lukewarm quote unquote Christians
Revelation 3:15-16 describes it it says
I know your works you know there's a lot
of people that'll say
ah you're you're trying to say we're
saved by works I don't think we're saved
by works alone
but right here in Revelation the last
book of the Bible as New Testament as
you can get says I know your works
that you are neither cold nor hot I
could wish you were cold or hot so then
because you are lukewarm and neither
cold or hot I will vomit you out of my
mouth how does he know they're lukewarm
how does he know I know your works that
you're lukewarm
in these last days there will be great
deception in the church and Satan will
seduce them into lawlessness
the churches are drunk on the wine of
Babylon but God is calling his people to
come out of her before the plagues are
poured upon the Lawless there are so
many churches today that say we don't
have to keep the command Commandments or
maybe we don't have to keep one of The
Commandments
whosoever breaks the least commandment
will be called least by the kingdom of
heaven so even one
whoever breaks one breaks them all right
if you break one you break them all
whoever breaks the least will be called
the least
this is the wine of Babylon in the
church today ah we don't got to keep
that one that's an Old Testament one
they're all Old Testament that's what
Jesus said not a new one but the from
the beginning so clear
come out of her my people
Revelation 18 2-6 says and he cried
mightily with a strong voice saying
Babylon the great is Fallen is fallen
and is become the habitant habitation of
devils man
and the hold of every foul spirit and a
cage of every unclean and hateful bird I
think it's interesting that the New
Testament Revelation mentions a unclean
bird because clean and unclean Animals
still exist just just to let you know
for all nations have drunk of the wine
of the wrath of her fornication
why is it talking of these about these
what what do these words mean wine
fornication it's not talking about
literal this is symbolic
what does it mean to be drunk on the
wine of her fornication
and the kings of the Earth have have
committed fornication with her and the
merchants of the Earth are waxed Rich
through the abundance of her Delicacies
and I heard another voice from Heaven
saying come out of her my people that ye
be not partakers of her sins and that ye
receive not of her plagues
for her sins have reached unto heaven
and God hath remembered her iniquities
man I've been peeking out this
microphone
come out of her my people that ye be not
partakers of her sins and that ye
receive not of her plagues for her sins
have reached unto heaven and God hath
remembered her iniquities lawlessness
so apparently it does matter what you do
it does matter if you're Lawless or not
your Works matter because he's judging
by your works and by iniquities reward
her even as she rewarded you and double
unto her double according ording to her
Works
wait a minute the Judgment has doubled
up because of her works
in the cup which she hath filled fill to
her double all right this is all kind of
King Jamesy language what it's saying is
that there are churches out there who
are drunk on the wine of Babylon they're
saying
they're saying a lot of false things
false teachings that's what the wine
means the wine is doctrines and there's
so many churches out there that are
saying look man we don't get we're New
Testament Christians man we don't got to
keep that old stuff we're not under the
law we're under grace
and that's how Satan talks deception is
99% truth but 99% truth is not truth
it's deception and so there's a lot of
churches out there and God is saying
he's calling them his people come out of
her my people come out because the
plagues are about to come down and I
don't want you to participate in her
sins and be worthy of the plagues come
out do what the will of my father is if
you love me keep my Commandments come
out do keep my Commandments
God refers to lawlessness as a
this is why it's talking about
fornication and all this stuff I was
Wonder I was hoping that this would make
sense when it says fornication what does
that mean because it's not really
talking about fornicating with some
of Babylon it's a symbolic because
God refers to lawlessness as whoredom as
a harlot as an adulterer in Matthew 16:4
he said a wicked and an adulterous
generation seeketh after a sign and
there shall be no sign given unto it but
the sign of the Prophet Jonas and he
left them and departed so Jesus is
talking about
adultery in a spiritual sense if we are
the bride of Christ what would it mean
to commit adultery on him to break his
laws and to go after false idols and to
do to do everything that he said not to
do is to commit adultery on him because
the Commandments are the laws of love
and if you love me you'll keep my
Commandments and if you are in a
relationship if you're the bride of
Christ and you break his laws of love
you commit adultery on on Christ that's
what it means Hosea 9:1 says Rejoice not
o Israel for joy as other people for
thou Hast gone a whoring from thy God
thou Hast loved a reward upon every corn
floor so he's saying look when you guys
turn your backs on me and stop listening
to me you went a whing you're like a
now you're not my bride because
you are disob oing you're breaking the
laws of Love judges 2:17 says and yet
they would not hearken unto their judges
but they went a whoring after other gods
and bowed themselves unto them they
turned quickly out of th out of the way
which their fathers walked obeying the
Commandments of the Lord but they did
not so so what is a whing
not obeying the Commandments is what
what it says right here a whing is when
you don't keep the Commandments of God
Revelation is still calling these people
his people that's what I'm trying to say
he's not saying they're not his people
but he's saying it is time to repent
it's time to come out of her we're in
the last days people it's time to wake
up keeping the Commandments in the last
days does does the New Testament talk
about keeping the Commandments yes or no
Revelation 12:17 says and the dragon
which is Satan was wroth with the woman
or angry with the woman which is the
church God's people and went to make war
with who with the remnant of her seed
which keep the Commandments of God and
have the testimony of Jesus Christ
that's who Satan hates the most
Satan hates those who are living
according to God's will who are keeping
the Commandments of Love who are in a
true relationship with Christ that's who
he hates Revelation 14:12 says here is
the patience of the Saints here are they
that keep the Commandments of God and
have the faith of Jesus look some people
say there's a new commandment this says
the Commandments of God not the new
commandments of Jesus not some other
crazy law rules it's just the
Commandments of God Revelation 22:14
says blessed are they that what do his
Commandments that they may have right to
the tree of life and may enter into the
gates into the city
look at this guys who is going to be
able to enter into the gates of the city
and have right to that tree of life
those who keep the Commandments of God
because they're blessed look people are
saying if you keep the Commandments of
God you're cursed don't put me under
that old bondage don't put me under the
law I'm free
that's not what the Bible says
slavery comes from being in bondage to
Satan Freedom comes in the law of
Liberty that's what James calls it the
law of Liberty and freedom
so where is this all going because we're
bringing up Revelation and everything
there's some that are
going to be damned and there's some that
are going to make into the kingdom and
it's all about the Seal of God and the
mark of the beast and all this stuff
plays into this Deuteronomy 6 5-8 we
need to have the Seal of God not the
mark of the beast right everybody agrees
with that we need to be sealed not
marked well in Deuteronomy 6 5-8 it says
and thou shalt love the Lord thy God
with all thine heart with all thy soul
with all thy might and these words which
I command thee this day this is the
Commandments of the Lord the words that
I command thee this day shall be in
thine heart we already looked at that
right the Commandments are on our heart
and thou shalt teach them diligently
remember it said blessed are they that
do and teach them unto their children
and shall talk of them when thou sest in
thine house and when thou west by the
way and when thou liest down and when
thou risest up we need to be doing and
talking and teaching these Commandments
all day long
but we're doing the opposite we're
telling people you don't have to keep
them and thou shalt bind them for a sign
you know this word sign in the Hebrew is
h226 and it's the same exact word as
Mark
so these are the mark of God not the
mark of the beast they will be a sign
upon thine hand and they shall be as
frontless between thine eyes look at
that to be sealed by God is to have his
Commandments in our hand which means the
O the obedient works of our hands and in
our forehead which means the beliefs of
our mind that's how you're sealed in the
last days Exodus 13:9 says and it shall
be for a sign the same word Mark unto
thee upon thine hand and for Memorial
between thine eyes that the Lord's law
may be in thy mouth what is this sign
that's in the hand and between the eyes
the Lord's law Deuteronomy 11:18 says
therefore shall ye lay up these my words
in your heart which of which of the
Lord's words are in our heart his
Commandments right and in your soul and
bind them for a sign or Mark upon thine
hand that they may be as frontlets
between your eyes
man this stuff's so clear if you want to
be sealed in the last days it's those
who keep the Commandments of God that
have right to the tree of life it's
those keep the Commandments that the
dragon is angry with it's those who keep
the Lord's law in thy hand and between
the forehead that are sealed and not
marked by the Beast so if the Seal of
God is his Commandments in the obedient
works of our hands and the beliefs of
our mind meaning that we believe God's
Commandments and we do them because
that's how we show that we love him then
what is the mark of the beast it's the
opposite it means we don't believe the
Commandments and we don't do the
Commandments that's the mark of the
beast it's not a microchip it's not a
UPC code it's not some debit card I know
people are going to get triggered by
that
I'm not endorsing any of those things
but when that one verse people make a
whole Doctrine out of one verse that
says if you if you're marked by the
Beast if you're not marked by the Beast
you will not be able to buy sell or
trade that's what it says that's a
punishment that's not the mark the Mark
isn't some form of curse currency the
punishment for not getting the mark
which is obedience to the Beast instead
of God if you don't obey the Beast you
will not be able to buy or sell it also
says you're going to be in prison 10
days and ultimately beheaded those are
all punishments for not worshiping the
Beast
obedience and belief is worship but if
we trust and Obey believe and Obey
Christ will be sealed in our foreheads
and we will not have mark of the beast
and we will have right to the tree of
life it's that simple there's no mystery
to it it's all in God's word let the
word of God interpret itself Revelation
is written in symbols there's not really
going to be a woman standing on the moon
clothed with the sun there's not really
going to be a harlot riding a
seven-headed dragon drinking blood all
these are symbols and no one's going to
be literally sealed in their forehead
either when it says that God's people
are going to have a seal in their
forehead do you think that's literal
that people God's people are going to be
walking around with some seal on the
forehead no and if that's not the case
then the mark of the beast is the same
way it's symbolic Babylon doesn't even
exist today it's been gone you
[clears throat] know when it talks about
Israel it's talking about God's people
when and it's not talking about a nation
it's talking about the Believers when
it's talking about Babylon it's talking
about those who do not believe those who
are not God's people this is all
symbolic guys
I hope this is making sense man I'm
getting fired up [snorts] because I love
God's word I love how clear it is the
law and testimony this is another
indication that the seal is the law
because it says Revelation 1217 says
wait a minute we just read that one okay
and the dragon was wroth with the woman
who went to make war with the remn of
her sea to keep the Commandments of God
Isaiah 8:16 says bind up the testimony
seal the law among my disciples wait a
minute what's the seal what were we just
told that the seal was it's the law and
the testimony
because Isaiah 8:20 says to the law and
to the testimony if they speak not
according to this word it's because
there's no light in them and who is the
light that's in US Christ
so if we want to be sealed with the Holy
Spirit that's why a lot of people say
that the seal is the holy spirit I
believe that 100% the seal is having the
Holy Spirit the spirit to be holy that
comes from Christ the Holy Spirit not
the spirit of antichrist if we have the
Holy Spirit then we will keep the law
and the testimony it says right here to
the law and to the testimony if they
speak not according to this word if
you're saying we don't got to keep that
you're not speaking according to this
word to the law and to the testimony if
you speak not according to this word
it's because there's no light or no
Christ in them no Holy Spirit in them
Revelation 2:5 says
remember therefore from whence Thou Art
Fallen repent
and do the first Works look at this
Revelation is talking about repentance
and works or else I will come upon thee
quickly and will remove thy Candlestick
out of its place except thou repent look
at these words he said if you speak not
according to this word the law and the
testimony you have no light in you now
here it says if you don't have these
works I'm going to remove your candle
which is light the light will be removed
from you if you don't repent and keep
the first works this is so clear guys
I'm just praying for you guys that this
will make sense that you'll look at this
and say what have I been doing the word
is so clear how have I believed these
false prophets that have been telling me
that the law is done away with that we
don't have to keep any of them
and what about one what if there's one
should we break even one of The
Commandments
what about the Sabbath commandment you
realize it's the fourth Commandment this
is not some Mosaic law thing and we're
going to go into it that it's it started
before any laws were written down Exodus
20 8 through 11 says remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy six days
shalt thou labor and do all thy work but
the seventh day is the Sabbath of the
Lord thy God in it you in it Thou shalt
not do any work thou nor thy son nor thy
daughter Thy manservant Thy maid servant
nor thy cattle nor thy stranger that is
within thy Gates so it's saying the
seventh day not any other day I'm not
saying you can't worship God every day
do do that but the seventh day is date
night with God set everything aside
don't go to that 9 to5 and punch in the
clock where you have to do whatever the
boss tells you to do don't don't uh go
to the carnival or to the grocery store
or restaurant don't work other people
other people are going to have to slave
for you if you go out to eat on Sabbath
the seventh day is the Sabbath of the
Lord thy God
and it says for six days the Lord made
Heaven and Earth the sea and all that in
them is and rested on the seventh day so
there's no question about what day it is
it's not the second day the first day
Eighth Day some people call it wherefore
the Lord blessed the Sabbath day and
hallowed it all right notice it's
talking about creation week here this
goes Way Beyond way before
the Ten Commandments this goes way
before the Ten Commandments it's talking
about that he rested on the seventh day
that he created the Earth in six and he
rested on the seventh day and what's it
say right there it says that the Lord
blessed the Sabbath day and hallowed it
can we make something that God blessed
and hallowed no longer blessed and
hallowed no can we make another day
blessed and hallowed no
which day was it the seventh the one
that he blessed at creation not at Mount
Si
right here it says God blessed that
creation we're going to go right to
Genesis because some people say the
Sabbath was a shadow
a shadow was something that pointed to
Christ and when Christ came and died for
for the sins or died to he fulfilled
those things things like Passover we no
longer sacrifice a lamb at Passover
because Jesus fulfilled that ordinance
that shadow
that lamb was a shadow of Christ he died
the perfect sacrifice once and for all
once for all and Jesus said uh no longer
the blood of bulls and goats and none of
these things
so we don't have to keep that anymore
because it was a shadow the Sabbath is
not a shadow this didn't come at in the
days of Moses it wasn't written in a the
law of Moses
Genesis 2 2 and 3 says and on the
seventh day this is Genesis first book
of the Bible on the seventh day God
ended his work which he had made and he
rested on the seventh day from all his
work which he had made and God blessed
the seven s th day and Sanctified it
because that in it he had rested from
all his work which God created and made
so is the fourth Commandment valid today
after all the study we did about if you
love me keep my Commandments the all the
Commandments hang on love all these
things is the fourth Commandment valid
and some people say yes but
Jesus is my Sabbath and I keep it every
day
well if you keep the if you keep the
Sabbath every day then you don't have a
job and you don't have a life basically
and you don't shop you don't go to a
restaurant you can't keep the Sabbath
every day when the literally is in the
Commandment that says don't work don't
work your servants and don't work a
stranger or an animal
so therefore you're not keeping the
Sabbath every day if you're doing those
things if we look at the four
commandment it says if you break the
least commandment you'll be called least
in the heaven does the fourth
Commandment say
remember me in your heart on this day
and really you can keep it every day no
it says this is a special day that's
been blessed and hallowed from the
beginning of time
and it's a blessing to get to not work
to get to spend time with God and in his
word like why are we trying to fight
against this thing why are we trying to
fight against relationship time with God
you know people say this is Works based
you're saying it's Works no it's the
opposite of Works
rest is the opposite of Works
relationship time with God is the
opposite of works every Commandment that
we willfully keep we won't kill we won't
steal and all these things those are
works if you don't kill somebody that's
a work but resting and spending time
with God for 24 hours that's the
opposite of work it's blessed it's rest
it's relationship
we have to look at this like we're the
bride of Christ and he wants a date
night with us he wants to spend time
with his bride and he says can you give
me a whole 24 hours once a week please
you're so busy all the time you're
always working and doing all these
things can you please spend time with me
for 24 hours please that's all I ask
blessed it I made it date night it's his
night we don't get to choose the day
man [clears throat]
it really makes my heart break for God
so notice that God blessed it and
hallowed it on the seventh day it was
blessed before creation if you look up
the word Sabbath in the Bible you will
actually see it before the Ten
Commandments
when you look it up Exodus 16 comes
before Exodus 20 right that's when the
10 Comm Commandments came Exodus 20
that's when Moses came down with the Ten
Commandments written in law written in
stone but in Exodus 16
it says six days ye shall gather it
talking about the Mana but on the
seventh day which is the Sabbath in it
there shall be none
so when God said in the Ten Commandments
remember the Sabbath day for one he
didn't mean forget it for another you
can't ask somebody to remember something
that they've never heard of like
remember when you went to the moon no I
don't so if he said remember the Sabbath
day it had to been something they
already aware of yes because Jesus did
it on the seventh day he blessed it way
back then at creation and then he said
hey on the Sabbath day you're not going
to have Mana either and he mentioned the
Sabbath by name before the Ten
Commandments ever came
but are we keeping the Commandments are
keeping the Commandments still important
that's the question we already went
through all this stuff but in Colossians
23-17
it says and you being dead in your sin
and the uncircumcision of your flesh
hath he quickened together with him
having forgiven you all trespasses
blotting out the handwriting of
ordinances that was against us okay
we're going to look at what was that
which was contrary to us and took it out
of the way nailing it to his cross this
is a common verse people say look no no
no I don't have to keep the Commandments
they were nailed to the cross all right
there is something nailed to the cross
but it says the handwriting of
ordinances which was against us let's
look at that
and having spoiled principalities and
powers and made a sh a show of them
openly triumphing over them in it let no
man therefore judge you in meat or in
drink or respector of a holy day or of
the of the new moon or of the Sabbath
days
which are a shadow of things to come but
the body is of Christ okay this is this
is tricky I I'll admit this might look
like if somebody if your pastor showed
you this and said no no no don't listen
to that guy about the Sabbath look at
this verse right here boom and he reads
that you know how many people I've done
a whole study like this and they're like
whoa yeah yeah it's the fourth
Commandment right there blessed and hell
that creation Jesus said if you let me
keep my Commandments they go ask their
pastor and the pastor says look at this
and they're like nope I don't believe
any of that stuff you told me I'm just
like what what you threw away half the
Bible over one verse come on man this is
how you have to study the Bible line
upon line precept upon precept here a
little there a Little by the mouth of
two or three Witnesses this is how we're
told to to study Jesus said don't even
break the least one but so what does
this mean if we see one verse that seems
to contradict
50 verses the problem is probably with
that one verse not 50 right that's just
logical rational
now if we want to study this verse and
figure out what does it mean because it
seems to contradict we need to look at
look at it deeper right and then we
weigh out the evidence where does the
evidence weigh does it weigh for keeping
the Commandments or not keeping the
Commandments all right so is the the
handwriting of ordinances which was
against us and it included meat and
drink offerings and a respector of holy
days and new moons and Sabbath days
notice the language there Sabbath days
and it says these are all a shadow now
we just pointed out that the Sabbath was
not a shadow right so that already
eliminates the Sabbath right there
honestly the sabath is not a shadow
therefore it's not the shadow of things
to come
but
let's look at that the handwriting of
ordinances that was against us is this
the Ten Commandments
notice that it said Sabbath days that
means plural the when it when it
referred to the Sabbath it said the
seventh day is the Sabbath of the Lord
thy God it doesn't say the seventh day
is a Sabbath days of the Lord thy God it
says it's the Sabbath day
and right here it says Sabbath days
which were shadow of things that come so
let's let's see does the Bible talk
about any Sabbath days that are a shadow
yes all these Jewish sabbaths right here
it says the four sabbaths before
Passover on this calendar here are many
Sabbath days special sabbaths of spring
it says four special sabbaths occurred
just before the start of spring so we're
not talking about the Sabbath day which
Jesus commanded which he blessed and
hallowed at creation
that's not a shadow so therefore when we
read this verse and it says we're BL
that what was nailed to the cross was
blotting out the handwriting of
ordinances which was against us is the
Sabbath against us is resting and
spending time with God for 24 hours
against us no are any of the other Ten
Commandments against us no they're for
us they're the laws of love right we
went through that the book of the law is
against us the book not the stones but
the book Deuteronomy 31:26 says take
this book of the law what is this this
is a a book that Moses wrote with his
hand the handwriting of Moses which was
against us take this book of the law and
put it in the side of the Ark not inside
the ark that's where the Ten
Commandments were but put it in the side
of the Ark in a pocket of the Covenant
of the Lord thy God that it may be there
as a witness against thee so the Ten
Commandments are for us we agree right
they're the laws of love we went through
this if you love me keep my Commandments
that the Commandments equal love so the
book of the law is not against us
because love is not against us right
okay so what was against us which was a
shadow of things to come which was a
handwriting which was blotted and nailed
to the cross that was the book of the
law
that was the law of Moses that was the
Mosaic law it has been taken out of the
way nailed to the cross thankfully we
don't have to sacrifice animals and
stone our children and all these things
right that was the law of Moses we are
not under that law we're under grace
thank God we don't have to Stone our
children right the handwriting of Moses
in Deuteronomy 31:26 says we just read
that but the Commandments of God on the
right says Exodus and uh Exodus 4 420 it
says and he took and put the testimony
into the ark and set the staves on the
ark and put The Mercy Seat above upon
the ark so the Ten Commandments are in
the ark and the handwriting of Moses was
in the side of the Ark and it stood
against us this is how you differentiate
between the two so does the M does the
day matter then because it just said
don't judge any man in holy days and all
that stuff Romans 14 14 5-6 kind of adds
to that it sounds like one man esteemeth
one day above another another esteemeth
every day alike let every man be fully
persuaded in his own mind
sounds like hey man you might think the
Sabbath is a seventh day but in my mind
it's Sunday
he that regardeth the day regardeth it
unto the Lord okay today is for the Lord
and He that regardeth not the day to the
Lord doth not regard it he that eat e
this is interesting point why do we go
into eating all of a sudden he that
eateth eateth to the Lord for he giveth
God thanks and he that eateth not to the
Lord eateth not and giveth God thanks so
why' we go from regarding a day to
eating or eating not regarding the day
or not regarding the day eating or
eating not unto the Lord that's what it
says that he eateth not
and giveth God thanks so let's check it
out the context of the context is
fasting
so in this context when you look at it
um this comes from this the website's
down here at the bottom and this is a
commentary and it says we do not find
this surprising as the one mandatory
fast prescribed in the Old Testament
occurred in conjunction with confession
of sin on the day of atonement so this
is talking about on the day of atonement
now he's saying look let everyone be
persuaded in your own mind whether you
want to eat to the Lord or not eat to
the Lord whether you want to keep this
day for fasting or not for fasting look
there's there's no mandatory day to fast
but the Pharisees were saying look it's
a Wednesday you must fast or whatever
where afflict yourself as equivalent to
fasting so when you see in the Bible in
Leviticus 16: 2934 where it says afflict
yourself
or afflict your souls
it means fasting
with regard to the Pharisees first
century Jews regarding fasting as a mark
of General piety not just repentance and
the Pharisees were known for fasting on
Mondays and Thursdays despite the unus
I don't know what that word is despite
the honorous burdens the Pharisees
created with their interpretations the
com people held a favorable view of of
them so it makes sense why they would
question not only why jesus' disciples
did not fast as John's disciples did but
also why they did not fast as the
Pharisees did look at this this is so
clear Paul's saying look right right
back here
he's saying let one man esteem another
uh let one man esteem one day above
another another esteemeth every day of
life like let every man be persuaded in
his own mind this is talking about is
this day mandatory to fast yes or no
well Paul's saying no let everyone
decide for themselves when they should
or should not fast and then he goes into
it he breaks it down he's like you know
who he regards the day to the Lord or he
regardeth not the day to the Lord he
that eateth or eateth not to the Lord
and give thanks to God this what it's
all about it's all about fasting
mandatory fast days that the Pharisees
kept and they were saying you know why
don't why don't your Apostles fast like
the Pharisees
some people say that Jesus broke the
Sabbath do you believe that if Jesus was
sinless and we read that sin is
transgression of the law do we believe
that Jesus is a sinner he broke the
Sabbath all right Matthew 12 1-15 says
at that time Jesus went on the Sabbath
day through the corn and his disciples
were and hungered and began to pick the
ears of corn and to eat but when the
Pharisees saw it now do we do we listen
to the Pharisees do we like what they
teach no they're constantly accusing
Jesus of being a glutton and a drunk and
hangs out with Sinners and all these
things but when the Pharisees saw it
they said unto him Behold thy disciples
do that which is not lawful to do on the
Sabbath day we just read the Sabbath
commandment we just read it it said
don't work
don't work your slaves don't work your
cattle
and don't work a stranger where in there
did it say thou shalt not pluck an ear
of corn and eat it with with thy
disciples it's not in there that's the
whole point the Pharisees were always
adding to the law constantly they would
do things like oh you can't take more
than 15 Steps on the Sabbath and so
we're going to have a a string and as
long as we're holding the string the
steps don't count and oh I can make a
gentile hold my tray and carry it well
that's making a gentile work on the
Sabbath they had all these Twisted ways
of trying to keep the law which were
legalistic and incorrect
including putting boxes of scripture on
their forehead and in their hand when it
was all about having the law in our
beliefs of our mind and in the works of
our hands they did everything wrong are
we going to listen to them when they say
wait a minute he's doing what's unlawful
to to do on the Sabbath day but he said
unto them have ye not read the book uh
have you not read what David did when he
was and hungered and they that were with
him how he entered into the house of God
and did eat the showbread which was not
lawful for him to eat neither for them
which were with him but only for the
priests or have ye not read the or have
ye not read in the law how that the on
the Sabbath days the priest in the
temple profane the Sabbath and are
blameless now this is not talking about
breaking the Sabbath as a priest what is
your job your job is to do what a priest
does and preach teach the law sacrifice
animals
all the rituals right now a priest is in
the temple on the Sabbath day and he's
working but he's his work is God's work
and therefore it's not breaking the law
he's doing what God told him to do so
therefore the priest is not breaking the
Sabbath he's blameless but I say unto
you that in this place is one greater
than the temple but if ye had known what
this manth
what this man if what this meth but if
ye had known what this meanthe
and not sacrifice ye would not have
condemned the Guiltless for the son of
man is Lord even of the Sabbath day now
this is where people get twisted they're
like no Jesus is the lord of the Sabbath
that's right I worship the lord of the
Sabbath
because he said the Sabbath is the
seventh day is the Sabbath of the Lord
thy God
so if the Sabbath is the Sabbath of the
Lord thy God and he's the lord of the
Sabbath what does that mean it means
that we should keep his day that he
commanded that he blessed and hallowed
that creation right we serve the Lord of
the Sabbath
and the seventh day is the Sabbath of
the Lord thy God if God has a day
because this is another one people say
that John the Revelator was in the
spirit on the Lord's day look they build
a whole Doctrine out of that verse it
never says anywhere in the Bible that
the Lord's day is Sunday the Lord's day
is the Sabbath the Sabbath of the Lord
thy God clear's day we're getting script
we're getting Doctrine from Babylon you
know it was the papacy the ca the
Catholic church that said the Lord's day
is Sunday that did not come from the
Bible
when they accused him of breaking the
Sabbath he said in verse 10 and behold
there was a man which had the hand
withered and he asked them saying is it
lawful to heal on the Sabbath days that
they might accuse him and he said unto
them what man shall there be among you
that shall have one sheep and if it fall
into a pit on the Sabbath day will he
not lay hold on it and lift it out how
much then is a man how much then is a
man better than a sheep wherefore it is
lawful to do well on the Sabbath days
what's he saying he's saying it's good
to do good on the Sabbath because the
Sabbath is a blessing and it's good to
help people and to heal people on the
Sabbath so here's two instances where
the Pharisees accused Jesus of breaking
the Sabbath and it wasn't breaking the
Sabbath because there's no commandment
there's no part of the fourth
Commandment that says you can't eat corn
plucked from a field on the Sabbath day
it also doesn't say you can't heal a man
on the Sabbath day so Jesus never broke
the Sabbath Nob brainer because he never
sinned
he broke the Pharisees law
so the Sabbath is a blessing not a
burden Mark 3:4 says and he saith unto
them it is lawful to do good on the
Sabbath days that's what we just read so
he's saying it's good to do good then
Jesus said unto them I will ask you one
thing is it lawful on the Sabbath days
to do good or to do evil to save life or
to destroy it he's like come on guys if
we can't heal on the Sabbath what kind
of blessing is the Sabbath the Sabbath
is a blessing not a burden remember keep
his Commandments and they're not
Grievous to you or they're not
burdensome to you because the Sabbath is
a blessing
so the sa the the Pharisees were adding
to the law all the time we we talked
about it but here it shows it in Matthew
23 1-9 it says then spake Jesus to the
multitudes and to his disciples saying
the scribes and the Pharisees sit in
Moses seat all therefore whatsoever they
bid You observe that observe and do but
do not after their works for they say
and do not so he's saying look the
Pharisees are hypocrites he called them
snakes and Vipers and whitewashed tombs
full of dead men's bones he said look
they say it and they don't do it for
they bind heavy burdens and Grievous to
be born so he's saying look what they
their laws are a burden but remember we
keep the Commandments and they're not
Grievous right so the Ten Commandments
are not Grievous even the fourth one
it's a blessing [snorts] and lay them on
men's shoulders ERS but they themselves
will not move them with their with one
of their fingers but all their Works
they do for to be seene of men they were
just doing it for a show they make broad
their
fla trees and enlarge the borders of
their garments and love the up uppermost
rooms at feasts and the chief seats in
the synagogue and greetings in the
markets look man these people are all
about look at me and to be called of men
r Rabbi Rabbi but be not ye called Rabbi
for one is your master even Christ and
all ye are Brethren so don't be calling
people Master call them brother and call
no man your father upon the Earth for
one is your father which is in heaven
man I hope this is clear I hope this is
clear that the Pharisees were adding to
the law they're adding burdens and he
said look they don't even keep it nobody
can keep this stuff
and if they do they're doing it for show
The Ten Commandments are not burdensome
to us and the Sabbath is a blessing
Sabbath in the New Testament I've heard
people say look man there's no Sabbath
in the New Testament I ain't never seen
it well here it is Mark 1 12 through 22
and straight way he called them and they
left their father zebede in the ship
with the hired servants and went after
him and and they went into Capernaum and
straightway on the Sabbath day he
entered into the synagogue and taught so
this is a disciple teaching on the
Sabbath day so they keep in the Sabbath
they go into the synagogue and teach on
the Sabbath day and they were astonished
at his Doctrine for he taught them as
one that had Authority and not as a
scribe
uh that might have actually been Jesus
that did that Mark 6 1-2 says and he
went out from th and came into his own
country and his disciples followed him
and when the Sabbath day was come he
began to teach in the synagogue this is
Jesus when the Sabbath day came he began
to teach in the synagogue and many
hearing him were astonished saying from
whence hath this man these things
and what wisdom is this which is given
unto him that even such Mighty works are
wrought by his hand Luke 4:1 14-16 30
and 31 and Jesus returned in the power
of the spirit into Galilee and there
went out a Fame of him through all the
region round about and he and he taught
in their synagogues being glorified of
all
and he came to Nazareth where he had
been brought up and as his custom was as
jesus' custom was he went into the
synagogue on the Sabbath day and stood
up for to read Jesus been keeping the
Sabbath his whole life but he he passed
but he passing through the midst of them
went his way and he came down to
Capernaum a city of Galilee and taught
them on the Sabbath days
acts 133 through 15 says now when Paul
and his company loosed
from pathos
they came to perga in pamila
and John departing from them returned to
Jerusalem
but when they departed from perga they
came to Antioch in p Zia and went into
the synagogue on the Sabbath day and sat
down so this is talking about Paul and
some others John they departed and sat
down on the Sabbath and after the
reading of the law and the prophets the
rulers of the synagogue sent unto them
saying ye men and Brethren if ye have
any word of extortion
for the people say on so they're sitting
there listening to the sermon and the
whoever was preaching was like Hey if
you guys got anything to say say it acts
1342 through uh 42 through 25 42- 45
and when the Jews were gone out of the
synagogue look some people say only the
Jews they did that just to teach the
Jews that's what I've heard the
disciples went into the synagogues on
the Sabbath day the sole mission for
being there was only to win the Jews but
this says and when the Jews were gone
out of the synagogue the Gentiles
besought that the these words might be
preached to them the next Sabbath
now when the congregation was broken
broken up many of the Jews and religious
prelit followed Paul and Barnabas who
speaking to them persuaded them to
continue in the grace of God and the
next Sabbath day came almost the whole
city together to hear the words of God
but when the Jews saw the multitudes
they were filled with envy and spake
against those things which were spoken
by Paul contradicting and blaspheming so
listen if these Gentiles besought that
these words might be preached to them
the next Sabbath day why didn't Paul
just say hey guess what actually
tomorrow is the new Sabbath day come
back tomorrow and I'll preach again no
it says the next Sabbath nearly the
whole city came that's Jews Gentiles
worldly people everybody came on the
Sabbath
acts 161 13-15 says and on the Sabbath
day we went out into the City by a
Riverside where prayer was want to be
made and we sat down and spake unto the
women which restored thither so these
are some women sitting down having a
Bible study by the river on Sabbath
that's a great way to spend Sabbath go
out in nature read God's word spend time
with them and a certain woman named
Lydia a seller of purple in the city of
the city of thyra which worshiped God
heard us whose heart the Lord opened and
she attended unto the things which were
spoken of of Paul and when she was
baptized wow she went from like
overhearing this Bible study to coming
over and her heart was open and she's
like let me be baptized
when she was baptized in her household
she besought us saying if ye have judged
me to be faithful to the Lord come into
my house and abide there and she was and
she constrained us so this is a bible
study on Sabbath in the New Testament
and Paul was there acts 17 2-4 says and
Paul as his manner was as his manner was
went in unto them and three Sabbath days
reasoned with them out of the scriptures
this is what Paul did on the Sabbath
opening and Al alleging opening and Alle
an alleging
that Christ must needs have suffered and
risen again
from the dead and that this Jesus whom I
preach unto you is Christ and some of
them believed and consorted with Paul
and Silas and of The Devout Greeks and
great multitudes and of the chief women
not a few so look here we go again Paul
three Sabbath days reasoned out of the
scriptures that's what we should be
doing with our time
Acts 18:4 says and he reasoned in the
synagogue every every Sabbath and
persuaded the Jews and the Greeks so
Paul was a killer on the Sabbath man he
went out there and reasoned with them
every Sabbath the Jews and the Gentiles
here we go more about the Sabbath in the
New Testament Luke 2352
through 56 says this man went unto
pilate and beg the body of Jesus he and
he took it down and wrapped it in linen
and laid it in a s that was heun in
stone wherein never man was laid before
and that day was the preparation and the
Sabbath Drew on so if Jesus died on
quote unquote Good Friday and he
resurrected on Sunday the first day of
the week then Friday night was the
Sabbath was drawing on right
and the women also which came with him
From Galilee followed after and beheld
the seler and how his body was laid and
they returned and prepared spices and
ointments and rested the Sabbath day
according to the Commandments
wo here's a new testament Christian
Jesus already died they're anointing his
body and they said you know what it's
the Sabbath let's keep the Sabbath and
they go home and they come back on
Sunday they come back and find Jesus
Resurrected but they is said according
to the Commandments guys I hope
something here said was clear that Jesus
said if you love me keep my Commandments
that those who say they walk with him
and don't keep his Commandments are a
liar that the Commandments are good for
us love God love your neighbor that
they're a blessing that they're not a
burden all of them even the fourth
Commandment all Ten Commandments hang on
love and if we love God
will want to keep the first four
Commandments have no other gods before
him no Idols don't take his name in vain
and spend time with God on the day that
he blessed and hallowed at creation it's
a blessing not a burden I pray that this
was enlightening to you I pray if this
was something new you've never heard
before that you would take these words
to heart and that you would study them
out yourself but I'll encourage you
don't just go to your pastor and let him
give you one verse and say look this one
one verse debunked all the 50 verses
that that guy showed you don't fall for
that let no man deceive you come out of
her my people we're in the last days
Jesus is coming soon and I don't want to
partake of those plagues blessed are
they that do his Commandments they have
right to the tree of life and may enter
into the city I hope this was blessing
to you guys please give it a thumbs up
it really helps this message get out to
others that need to hear this in these
last days this is a vital message give
it a thumbs up if you're new here click
the Subscribe button and the
notification Bell so you don't miss
another video We Do videos like this all
the time we talk about deep topics we
talk about controversial topics we talk
about the truth the candid truth we love
you guys we'll see you next time if you
want to support this ministry you can do
so by checking out some of our
uh different methods of donating you can
do so on our website which is candid
truth.org there's a donate button and
you can do that through PayPal you can
even do monthly through that way if you
want to use cash app our cash apps on
the screen you want to do vinmo we got
venmo you want to do zel we got zel and
if you want to write a check just send
an email to us there's a way to contact
us on the website
uh every way you can help support us
helps us out we are doing this ministry
in faith we stepped away four months ago
from a full-time job to do what God has
called me and my wife to do and and
that's to do this ministry to get the
messages out that God's laid on our
hearts to help expose the deceptions of
the enemy in these last days if you
agree with that message if God has put
on your heart to S support that Ministry
through prayer through donations through
buying a cool t-shirt we got some
T-shirts you can do you can find those
on candid truth.org there's a a link
that says shop and we got this is only
three of many different shirts we have
the truth will set you free love is kind
be cool use your brain look we live in a
day and age where all the media all the
propaganda out there says it's it's not
cool to be smart you got people like
Steve Urkel and Screech being shoved in
the lockers and being bullied because
they're smart and who are the cool guys
the dumb ones they get all the girls and
all that look it's cool to be smart stop
falling for the propaganda use your
brain God gave it to you for a reason he
said come let's reason together
hope you guys enjoyed this message if
you did please like it please share it
with family and friends we love you we
can't do this without you and we'll see
you next time on candid truth